Leah, you just seem like you're like
seething with rage and I wish you would
just say what
>> I'm finding a through line. I'm building
evidence. I'm trying to have a
conversation without him and you're like
you're getting you're getting upset with
Stop talking, Max. Don't talk to me
anymore for the rest of the night.
You're on timeout.
>> Maybe. I thought I could fix him.
>> I think we could fix her.
>> Destiny broke me. My career died. My
girlfriend left me and I went bald.
>> Other than that, things are going well.
Okay. So, what happened is Connor and
Desessie had their crash out. Conor
said, "You're age playing with a
groper's wife." And they had this whole
fight and all this, right? Connor, you
come to find out that the guy, the devil
guy, the thing he told Connor was that
this woman, his his wife, his ex-wife,
whatever, was doing some sort of age
play where they she involved the right.
They were stepparents like doing
something to the
Connor asked the wife about it and the
wife said, "No, the husband's just
husband's just making it up because he
like wants to win in a breakup or he's
mad and all of this and he's making it
up." So Connor went on his merry way
like told Destiny you shouldn't engage
with these kinds of people anymore. They
obviously have some problems and it's
really bad, right? It seems like the
allegation has come out that now Destiny
got pictures of this guy's too, which is
crazy. back in well I I assume November
before. All right. But come to like this
month, Connor realizes that Destiny is
still texting this woman, the woman who
he thought was just doing age play with
him, some sort of babysitter, right? And
then Connor finds out that this woman
wrote into Mr. Girl and discussed like
explicitly not not just age play, not
just babysitter stuff, but fantasizing
about being the stepparents of each
other's and involving the in the role
play. Okay. And that changed
Connor<unk>'s mind basically immediately
once he found out that that was the
allegation, that the allegation was true
and that Destiny had continued to engage
with this woman after Connor had called
him out for it. And so that's like the
quick rundown of why Connor was so upset
and why he felt the need to go public
with a bunch of this stuff.
>> Hello, Connor. Welcome.
>> Let's go.
>> Hi, Lav. How are you?
>> I'm You know what? I'm doing so well.
>> This is what we're looking for.
>> All right. Well, where where do you want
to start?
Well, let's let's start with the
predator thing. I'm I'm interested
because you said that you still would
not call him a predator and that
confuses me because then that makes me
question why you brought anything up at
all
>> because so I think then as in now when
people bring up predator uh I think of
may maybe this is because I'm accepting
the colloquial term too much or whatever
um but I think of someone who's stalking
in the bushes you know
disabled people. Well, is is that not
what you're saying he's doing with the
mentally ill women?
>> No, because I think the mentally ill
women have some agency.
>> Well, of course. What I mean isn't just
Do you not think that you could rap a
girl who's drunk? You can only vegetable
if you
>> They have some agency.
>> Well, hold on. So, can you rap yourself
>> every day? I They're calling me the most
alive. Can we put the Can we put the
memes aside for a second? We are talking
about something serious.
>> We can.
>> So, for me, uh especially being in a
former law enforcement background, uh
rape is often times going to be
forcible. Of course, there's going to be
like drunk or incapacitated or people
who don't have the ability to consent,
etc., etc., etc. And so, while I think
the women that I'm criticizing Steven
for are mentally ill, I don't think that
they're so mentally ill that they are
incapable of giving consent in an adult
context. They are adults.
>> Okay. Interesting. I think that that
would call into a question that what
capable means in your definition of
capable. But um I did a quick Google
search and predator is an individual who
exploits others in an abusive
non-consensual manner, often using
power, coercion, or grooming behaviors.
And now I'm not an expert on the
dictionary,
but it does seem
as though even in your definition that
is what is happening.
>> Well, yeah, but do you want to um do you
want to call Anna Voir and see if she
thinks that Steven is a predator
>> or Brit?
>> I I I think
>> or Sherry might have a different Sherry
might have a different answer.
>> Get them all on Get him in here.
>> Okay. Well, I mean I I would, but a lot
of them um a lot of them want to move on
the regardless of whether
>> part of that is because of what's
happening to you, which is also an
exercise of power. Correct.
>> Uh sure. But
>> part of why Cherry doesn't want to be
involved in this at all is exactly that.
>> Sure. But what I would say is that
>> at some at some point somebody just
have, you know, and I I'm I'm sure you
guys might even identify with the
sentiment. At some point you just have
to have the balls to say you, right? I
mean, that's exactly what I did, and I
got I got lambasted for that, too.
>> Well,
so so here here's uh here's something
that I was talking to somebody else
about earlier tonight. One of the funny
things that I think happens is Steven
seems to attract and interact with and
find most interesting mentally ill
people who have uh poor reputations both
online or in real life, right? And yet
what makes them attractive in the first
place is their poor reputations, their
weird insights, their mental illness,
but then their mental illness and poor
reputations is what's used to dismiss
them.
>> So Conor, what we would call that is a
predator. You're absolutely right. Yes,
that is.
>> No, I don't. Okay. Once again, when I
I'm saying colloquially, I really would
like to move past the memes, but like
I'm not
>> I'm not being I'm not going to be
calling Steven
predator and invoking ideas of a creepy
man lurking in the bushes in order to
drug and women. That is not what I'm
accusing him of. And by the way, I think
part of the problem here is hyperbole. I
think part of the problem is whenever
somebody uh does criticize Stephen,
they'll engage in hyperbole. Um or
they'll they'll stake out the strongest
claim. And the strongest claim, I'm even
guilty of this. Um, stake out the
strongest claim that is insufficiently
evidenced when the truth is that there
are claims that are infinitely more
strong that are still damning.
like being a
>> well so for instance the um I think that
based off of the evidence that I
presented of the husband saying what he
said the wife saying what he said
Destiny admitting to age play but
minimizing it he at minimum engaged in
age play I think there's an above 70
with a mentally ill woman while being
sued for misconduct
>> right
>> now I think there's an above 70%. So, so
we already got age play. That That's
like dumb.
>> Wait, can I can I can I ask something?
>> Please go ahead.
>> I'll allow
>> I would like to separate criticisms of
poor strategy like you're doing this
while you're being sued for misconduct
from moral criticisms. Cuz I it feels
like when we blend those together, like
you're doing something immoral and
you're doing something stupid, then it
has a tendency to
I guess kind of soften the moral
criticism.
>> B, I guess I could try. But you do
understand that like in in the process
of mourning what is a six-year online
relationship and probably a two-year
friendship. I myself waffle between what
I think is like malevolent and what I
think is recklessness.
>> Right. So So
>> well, but I'm not I'm not Wait.
Malevolent and reckless are on a
spectrum from intentional to
unintentional. But I'm talking about a
criticism that is of the impact. This is
wrong to do because of how it impacts
others versus poor strategy because of
how it impacts you. It's not immoral to
blow to
>> himself. Like it's not immoral to screw
up his own lawsuit. It's just stupid.
But it's not like it's not wrong.
>> Well, well, hold on. So m maybe I can
bridge the gap here and I promise you
I'm not trying to be evasive or not do
what you're asking me to do. I promise
you I'm trying to fulfill what you're
asking me to do. Okay.
>> Um but I think that at some point it is
incumbent upon Steven where recklessness
is no longer an excuse. So for instance
um if we go through the Mr. report and
we look at a decade of broken
relationships and then we know that 2022
is the peak of the drama where you guys
are in orbit and then you get driven out
of orbit. Then we allegedly have a
calming period after 2022, but then this
all reexlodes in 2024. Well, then at
that point, he really should have
stopped reckless behavior in 2022 when
he was kicking you two out of orbit. But
the uh Brit situation in my opinion just
shows that he hasn't learned that his
recklessness,
his unintentional danger to other people
um is bad and harmful and it hurts other
people. And so at that point the
recklessness I think does become a moral
calculation where even if he claims
recklessness at this point he should
know like like like long overdue for him
to know that his recklessness damages
other people.
>> I see what you're saying but I'm a
little concerned for him.
So basically you're saying like he's
drunk driving.
>> He's drunk driving and he's consistently
hitting Yeah. Okay.
>> And that is people's like emotional
lives.
Yes, that's fair.
>> And by the way, we can make we can stake
out um if you want to work your way up
to like I think I think even his own
fans would admit recklessness.
>> If you want to work your way up to
Malefics, I'm fine.
>> No, no, no. I'm not. That's not what I'm
trying to do.
I'm saying that the DG
language around how to evaluate
Destiny's character and behavior
is always focused on always bringing it
back to strategy. So you can never say
he did something morally wrong. That
gets turned into and he did it while he
was being sued. like what an idiot
implying that what he should be doing is
I I don't know strategizing better and
doing whatever is best for him at all
times and it kind of blends together the
moral criticism of like he is doing harm
to people whether it's intentional or
not whether it's like organized or
compulsive like who knows what he's
really thinking versus
uh is he just being dumb and shooting
himself in the foot
>> if if I do that during this convers
ation. Please forgive me. It will be
subconscious.
>> I'm Yeah, I'm It's not I'm just I I just
want to point it out because I'm worried
that if those get mixed together, then
we can't really talk about like harm.
>> Sure.
>> Okay.
Um Steven's history is very well
documented. It's at minimum well
documented as chaotic. Um it's at
maximum uh documented as like toxic. And
I think you would use the word
predatory. I think you
>> abusive or predatory.
>> Yeah. Okay. Abusive. There you go. Um so
depending on how you perceive these uh
incidents over the past decade, decade
and a half. Um you're going to have
somewhere on the spectrum you're going
to have dysfunctional but funny or
you're going to have predatory or
abusive depending on how you perceive
the scenarios. So, in my opinion,
um, Britt, I'm just going to talk to
about people openly because I I think
when we hem and haw around the scenario,
I think it gets more silly. Britt is an
adult. Britt was smart enough in order
to get into the military. Britt has
trauma. Britt is seen a therapist about
her trauma. Britt has family who care
about her. In what world would it be
recommended to that woman to engage in a
longd distanceance communication uh
relationship with a man while married
and also de dealing with like
post-traumatic stress disorder and
military related trauma?
>> The answer is never. The answer is
never. No sane person would ever
recommend this for Brit. And yet she
chose to do it because she is a person
with agency. But wait, two things. One,
>> why are we talking about that?
>> Because uh why' you say that? Lav is
asking why I'm why I'm still insisting
on blaming Destiny's victims by
acknowledging that they are, you know,
uh that if anybody past this point
engages with Steven, then they should
know what they're getting into.
>> But but they should know what they're
getting into. They don't is the problem
is he keeps putting himself in
situations where these women
>> Why don't they
>> because because they're not full agents
because even you say they're extremely
mentally ill, Connor.
>> Yeah. I I think it feels like you're
saying they're mentally
>> I don't think mental illness is an
excuse to like lose all agency.
>> Mental ill. That's literally what keeps
people from buying guns. It keeps people
>> wait if it's if it Why mention that
they're mentally ill at all if it
doesn't impact their agency,
>> right?
>> It does impact their agency. It just
doesn't eliminate it.
>> Nobody's saying it's eliminated.
>> But to the extent to the extent that it
impacts it, isn't that the same extent
that it's
morally wrong to
with them?
>> Which is why I asked you earlier like
>> Well, funnily enough, we uh
>> a bunch of different things.
>> Sorry. Go ahead. I was I was this is why
I asked you earlier. There's a bunch of
different things. Can you only someone
in a coma? Obviously not. There's
different levels of agency. There's
different types of rape. There's
different types of abuse. There's
different types of agency. Obviously,
these women have very little
>> I I would think based off any current
evaluation of the law and the way in
which capacity and agency are evaluated.
I do not think that Steven is guilty.
>> Okay. At least I don't have any
evidence. I wouldn't call rape either,
but I'm talking about
>> my I think that we should get away from
trying to argue about what terms like
rape and predator mean.
>> But I I think that you're invoking their
mental illness
when you want to criticize him for being
self-destructive
and then ignoring their mental illness
when evaluating the morality of his
actions.
>> No, I'm not ignoring it. You you could
articulate how I'm ignoring it. I don't
think I'm ignoring it at all.
>> Well, I I think it's part of the reason
why I was willing to burn the bridge
with Stephen this past week
>> is because I found So, I found out No,
hold on. Let Let me articulate this and
you can tell me where I'm at. So, I
think in November, well, actually, let's
back up just a little bit. Please
indulge me or rant.
In February of 2025 or January of 2025,
Steven lost 99% of his orbiters and
friends, right? because of the Pixie
allegations.
And then everybody's been slowly
drifting back in. Well, I never left,
right? But I was not leaving because I
was hoping against hope that this was
going to be such an extreme situation
that he would wake up. And in November,
I find out that he's and my my logs are
out there. If you want to read the logs,
we could even read them out out think uh
out loud. But November, I find out that
he's a mentally ill woman. An obviously
mentally ill woman. I'm able to identify
her mental illness within
five minutes of talking to her. I know
that she's severely mentally ill,
>> right?
>> And so I say, "Hey, Stephen, the husband
of a mentally ill woman is telling me
that you engage in age play with a
mentally ill woman.
>> How did you come into contact?" Hold on.
Let me finish, please. Let me finish,
please.
>> Right. I say, "I like you for all of the
blow reasons, but you are destroying
yourself and you're making it impossible
to be your friend." Okay, that's where I
feel like you were alluding to the fact
that I'm uh I'm trying to excuse
Steven's behavior.
>> Well, now with Hold on, please. Please.
I promise you. But you're saying
something that I promise you I'm almost
done. I
>> can you not say what I'm what I mean in
the middle of the thing I'm not allowed
to respond to?
>> Sure. I will focus on what I'm saying,
but I would like the opportunity to
finish what I'm saying. And I promise I
am almost done.
>> Okay.
>> Sure.
>> When I found out that they were still
communicating in this past week, that is
inexcusable to me. It's inexcusable
because I gave him a shot across the bow
in November. It's inexcusable because of
the allegations that he has already been
under in reference to this situation.
It's inexcusable because of what's hap
uh happened with the Pixie case. It's
inexcusable because of his claimed uh
personal and professional ambitions. It
is inexcusable for him to be engaged
actively with this woman at this time.
>> Okay. My assessment of what you said is
that it does feel like there is a
blending
or eclipsing of the moral question with
the
is Destiny harming himself and his own
career question. Is is it reckless or
stupid? Feels like
you're not saying like, "Hey, you can't
do this because it's wrong to do to
other people."
>> Well,
>> that's interesting. I'm in I'm in the
room with the man who says you can
fantasize about whatever you want.
>> Well, well, yeah, but I don't think that
I don't think that Max would ever say
involve the
>> I didn't say you can wait a second. I
didn't say you can do whatever you want.
Okay. Those are different.
>> Well, hold on. Hold on, hun. May maybe
you could parse this apart for
>> Well, also maybe I'm a hypocrite and I'm
stupid. Like that that doesn't change
what doesn't change my point. My point
is that
>> Well, you Yeah, sorry. I'll try to
listen to your point separate from the
statement I just made. But I do think
that you're the guy who said that is
interesting. But sorry,
>> we we can I'm happy to be pressed on
that. I just it just feels like you're
speaking some of the DG language where
we can't just say
uh he's taking advant like you went to
call him a predator and say he's women
or whatever. You could say he's taking
advantage of people. There is a power
differential. There are things that are
unethical about what he's doing separate
from how they may harm his own career.
But it feels like you invoke mental
illness only when you're talking about a
vulnerability to him and how it might
harm him. But then when we try but then
when when Leah says, "But that same
mental illness also poses a danger to
the women you're saying are mentally
ill." And you're like, "No, they can
consent. They're adults. They got into
the military. They whatever."
>> Maybe he's the BPD girl.
>> That's
>> maybe
>> I I think that's fair. I think that's
fair, but I don't think it's
a a really a response to the idea that
it's not fair to the to out this.
>> You're right. It's not fair to the to
out this. However, my frustration with
this is that often times, and I'm not
saying you're doing this, but other
people are doing this. Some people will
hide behind the effects to potential
victims in order to allow somebody to
continue in bad behavior. And that's not
something that I'm gonna permit. What?
Like that that's not that's not part of
my calculation. So for instance, like
>> the whole thing's gonna come down.
>> Is Connor screaming
>> domestic violence battery scenario?
>> Well, if you arrest the perpetrator of
domestic violence battery, like Lab's
husband,
>> there's no way Lab's the only one.
>> Well, maybe he's going to be angry that
Lav reported him for domestic violence
battery. And then when he comes home,
>> he's going to beat the out of her even
harder in a context. It's just going to
be straight beating. there's gonna be no
sex
>> if there's a woman who deserves it.
>> So,
>> right. And so that calculation of, oh
well, if we expose this information or
if we take action against this person,
they're going to behave even worse.
>> That's not an incentive structure that I
can respond to.
>> Also, I feel like while you didn't
intend that, you were actually trying to
>> probably thread the ego involved here in
a way responsible of action. That's
just not a logic structure that I'm
responding responsive to.
>> Well, I just think that the whole the
only harm that's going to come from the
alleged role playing is if they find out
about it and then by broadcasting it,
you're the one who's telling them.
>> Okay. Then if that's true, the uh number
one, the people who engaged in the role
playing are the people who are
responsible for that, not me. Number
two, if the exposure of this alleged
scenario deters other people from
engaging in this behavior, then there
could be people who basically say, "Oh,
I was thinking about um I was listening
to this Mr. Girl thing. He was saying I
could fantasize about whatever I want."
And uh and yet somebody is being
publicly punished for enacting their own
fantasies uh because they were
antisocial. I'm not going to engage in
my antisocial fantasies. I would rather
have that impact on the world, truth be
told.
>> Okay. So you're actually So the problem
is it that you think that he's done
anything morally wrong then but you just
think that he's stupid.
>> No, I think that jerk. Okay. The
allegations
from this is what this is what gives me
>> I don't think Jesse would ever do
something like that.
>> Yeah. It's not it's not like there's I
don't think any proof, but obviously
it's something.
>> Let's move a little bit forward, okay?
because I've been accused of not
substantiating uh my claims with
sufficient evidence. Um I think there's
>> Sure. Um there's an 80 to 90% chance in
my opinion that they engaged in the
stepdad
fantasy and the step woman step
her fantasy. I think is 80% enough for
you to 80 80 to 90 is enough for you to
>> broadcast it feel like you want
>> Absolutely.
>> Yeah.
>> What are you planning on doing now?
You're out of the orbit. You've said
that you're out of the orbit.
>> What? Leah, what are you what are you
doing?
>> Well, I'm interested on I'm interested.
I'm asking questions that give me like
you're like grilling him.
>> I'm not grilling him.
>> It's fine. I don't care.
>> You are grilling him. But why?
>> I'm not grilling him. I'm asking
questions. I want to know where he is
psychologically without asking like how
are you psychologically? I'm trying to
get the real answer instead of like
>> you know where he is.
>> We've we've both been through this exact
thing and we did and said all the exact
same things that he's saying and doing
>> right.
>> Well, I don't know if it's the exact
same but yes.
>> I mean I mean bait pretty close.
>> Don't worry don't worry Conor that's
also a part of the process.
>> Not like hey are you on like t
>> Don't worry Conor that that revulsion at
being compared to Mr. Girl that's also a
part of the process. So, so what I would
say is, um, I'm out of orbit. Um, I'm
still going to cover his content. I
analogized it to
R. Kelly. Do you guys remember the song
Ignition?
>> Do I remember it? Of course.
>> Okay. Well, Ignition is so good. I don't
care that R. Kelly on 30year-olds.
Right.
So Steven is an interesting enough
internet debater that even if he
roleplayed I I won't even be specific.
Even if he did did some nasty freak,
I'll cover his debates when they're
interesting. I'll agree with him when I
think it's correct. I'll disagree with
him when I think it's correct. I'll
criticize him.
>> I'm trying to find a through line. And
this is why I asked you several
questions even though Max is
>> literally answering your question. But
go ahead, Leah.
>> No, I I I found a line. Leah, you just
seem like you're like seething with rage
and I wish you would just say what
>> I'm finding a through line. I'm building
evidence. I'm trying to have a
conversation without him and you're like
you're getting you're getting upset with
Stop talking, Max. Don't talk to me
anymore for the rest of the night.
You're on timeout. You're on 0%.
I'm just kidding.
>> Jeez, you guys are sensitive.
>> You're not on 0%. Um,
>> hang out with Don't call it the podcast
ever. Call it the most sensitive Scott
podcast. It's two control freaks in a
room. Um, but no, I'm I'm I'm trying to
understand through all of this because
you're you're saying and now maybe I am
actually grilling you because I
>> think that this is interesting because
you somehow as
antisocial behavior while you say the
most antisocial things I've heard out of
anyone. Even Steven, you say more you
say more antisocial things than even
Steven would say, I think. at least
loudly
>> like like how you don't like how you
don't care about um if R. Kelly onyold
girls or you don't care about the
victims. You don't care about women. You
don't think that you think that victims
are saying ignition is bad. You think
victims have agency. You think all these
things like or you think that they have
more agency than even is allotted. No,
we're not even talking about that.
Connor, let me finish. You're saying all
these things that are like expressly
antisocial. If we're even talking about
like if you fall under like the
philosophical school of thought which I
think is like close to something like
Emanuel Kant about like rules and about
like uh uh of of who we should be who we
ought to be your falling flat of even
your own
what I'm what I'm thinking is like okay
are or would Destiny's actions be per
permissive if he was like yeah I'm up
I'm supered up it is what it is I can't
stop doing this I'm up like would that
if he was like, "Yeah, I have a problem.
I need to help." Max does this to
people.
>> Would that change anything for you?
Could he still keep messing up and keep
messing up?
>> If he was actually on the Hold on. This
would be more explained by Christianity
than Kant.
>> So,
over this on Oh my god, Leah. Please,
>> please allow me to expand on the idea.
Okay.
>> Okay. I was in the church for 18 years,
right?
>> Okay. I was taught that
and murderers and eveners
are capable of achieving atonement and
forgiveness, right? Through God, maybe
not on the material plane, but through
God.
>> In order when you say, "Oh, well, if
Steven recognized that he was up, would
that instantaneously change my
calculation of the consequences that he
should suffer?"
>> No.
>> He would still have to go through the
process I just articulated.
>> He needs your help.
>> I agree. I agree.
>> I truly think his time would be better
served by speaking with a therapist
about his trauma, trying to recognize
the way in which he's sociopathic,
trying to realize that being pro-social
um benefits him, not just other people,
because sociopaths are very difficult to
reform. Yeah.
>> I I don't think this
>> seems like Max has something to say. So,
I'm sorry for telling you to shut the
up, Max. If you got something to say,
say it.
>> I think if you're going to make a joke,
it should be funny.
I'm not I'm not funny because I'm not a
Jew.
>> That was funny. There we go. Two. I
don't want to do a
What was Steven needs to get help
session?
>> What are you talking about? What are you
even
>> What is your What are your thoughts on
it then? What are What is your full
formed thought on all of this now?
>> On what's happening?
>> We'll do it. We'll do it.
I don't know if Connor has fully fledged
his out. We'll give him space to do it.
I want to hear yours. I'll do mine as
well, but let's hear yours.
>> I think that Connor is where we were and
where every orbiter
streamer member of the DGG cult finds
themselves eventually
where something clicks. You realize
you're a part of something that you
should not be part of.
your identity is destabilized cuz you
don't know what you've been doing and
you don't know who your friends are or
what's happening
and you think that if you explain
yourself it'll you can make it click for
other people. You think, "Well, I saw
this thing and it clicked for me and
surely
>> and you
>> it'll click for some other people. It'll
click for some people." You you'll peel
off a layer of the onion,
>> but the like you said, you bump into 50,
you're the problem.
>> At this point, the list of villains in
the mythology of this cult is so long
that they're they do really have an
endless ability to metabolize anything.
And you and you I'm sure you've I know
you've heard the counter narratives.
They don't make sense at all. Like, oh,
she was lying to make him look bad and
we now have proof of this. That the
standard of what proof is completely
changes. But Hutch was like, I don't see
I don't even see how this is perverted.
He just completely blanked out what was
being told to him.
>> It's very Sorry. That was actually that
was actually really funny to me where
we're literally talking about
>> it's weird
>> off to
>> and his analogy slash joke was well
because of neuroplasticity
if you do doggy style then eventually
you're going to want to dogs and I was
like
>> which in my experience is true
>> way to miss the point completely that
I'm like the only one who laughed I feel
I I feel I I'm truly sometimes blown
away
>> by what passes for content with some
audiences.
>> I think there's a lot of double speak
going on here about if the the women are
mentally ill or they're not mentally ill
or Connor was brainwashed.
>> But but you get mad at me when I prod
>> the double speak. So Connor's uh
brainwashed lemming who just goes from
organization to organization with no
sense of purpose like the army or his
own family or the church or whatever the
you're implying
or Connor is an adult and it was just
banter and it's always been like this
and the Twitch politics is just fun and
we just throw elbows sometimes.
And I think all of this introduces moral
confusion about the cult figure head
destiny.
>> It might.
>> But we but and that's why I thought
>> all of it all of it all of it serves to
introduce confusion about what happened.
>> This is why I thought it was useful to
tell to each of us tell what we think is
going on because I think I have a very
different opinion than you do.
>> Here here's a here's a potentially
productive point. So, Max, I agree with
you that some DJers, particularly the
people who are in my replies on Twitter,
can 100% exhibit uh cultlike behavior. I
I think that's just like descriptively
true. Um, however, I do think that
there's probably
subops of DGG who interact with uh
different levels of ferveny and also
have different levels of dedication to
Steven. And I think that the cultists
are actually like a subcategory of the
population. They're not necessarily the
entire thing. And so if it sounds like
I'm not like jumping on board like, "Oh
man,
>> I don't know what the percentages are or
whatever." It's partially because I
actually delineate like leveling
to a disagreement that you guys have
with me about how much it's a cult. I'm
pointing to internal contradictions
about the way you are talking about it
where you yourselves cannot decide how
much of a cult it is, how much his
behavior is immoral,
how much agency you yourselves have.
>> You don't know the most or is he just a
guy you like arguing with who sometimes
does irresponsible stuff with mentally
ill women?
>> These are not compatible views. You you
>> Well, the truth is probably in the
middle though, right?
>> I don't know where the truth
>> Not for the most black and white thinker
you've ever met in your life. No,
>> I don't know where the truth is. And I'm
coherence is not black and white
thinking. I'm saying that the way you
guys are talking about this whole
situation is internally contradictory.
You don't seem to have a position.
>> Can you give us
>> I have a position. I have a very strong
position.
>> Okay. Well, okay. Yeah. go ahead with
it. But I I was going to try to identify
a sole variable and then try to resolve
the incoherence. But uh Leah, if you
want to articulate your position, please
go ahead.
>> I I think that uh that the community can
act like a cult at certain points, but I
also think that Destiny, more so than
anything, is in a very codependent
relationship with his internet fame. And
I think that that makes him uh impulsive
and it makes him ego-driven and it makes
him and it makes him an addict. And I
think that because of that he's
completely out of control. I think that
some of the things he does on purpose I
think some of the things he doesn't do
on purpose.
>> This is an example of what I'm talking
about. You're asked to analyze is this
organization structurally a cult? And
within 20 words you're saying Steven is
egovenriven. This is not related to the
question that is put before you and it's
the question.
>> I said I said that I said I said it
accent.
>> Can you identify the question? What's
the question? What's the question you
want us to contend?
>> Max is actually seething now. Max is
going to punch a wall.
>> I'm not even really asking a question.
The question is is DG a cult. But my
critique is you slide between yes it is
and no it's not. Yes, I'm a victim. No,
no, I'm not a direct. I don't have
agency. The mentally women ill women
have agency. the mentally ill women are
victims. They don't have agency.
Destiny's a predator. No, actually, he's
just not that bad. And then not even
being able to stay on topic of like, is
it structure? And then we're talking
about the internal psychology. No, I
think he needs help. You're all over the
place. And the being all over the place
at a time, the being all over the place
and not being able to follow a single
conversational thread is a feature of
the cult. not being able to clearly
about what we're talking about is the
nature of conversation. But but hold on,
you it Well, Max, if you wanted to
resolve the incoherence, then what you
could have done is you could have set
expectations that this is effectively
going to be an interview run by you.
That's not what happened. Leah basically
invited me and said, "Hey, let's let's
all chat together and catch up." And I
said,
>> "That sounds not a response to any you
were like, tell me the question." The
question is, is DG a cult? And you're
like, okay, look,
>> you should have you should have prepped
me for this conversation. You didn't.
Now we're launching into a meta critique
of how I introduced the conversation.
>> Please stop. Please.
>> Do you think DG is a cult?
>> I think there's a subcomponent of DGG
that is a cult. Are you in it?
>> I think the bigger question is, can some
can something accidentally be a cult?
>> Is it a conscious cult?
>> Is it a conscious cult? Is it a cult? I
think conversation
>> but but but don't don't muddy the water.
Max wants to drive
>> unironically become violent.
>> Well, it is because it's distracting
from the pause to bear down on my
answer.
>> Listening. Okay.
>> No, I was not a part of the cult element
of DGG.
>> Okay. In your view,
>> you were part of the cool community part
which has shrunk since 2021 to 2022
as Destiny is revealed to be more and
more of a degenerate. in your words.
>> Yep.
>> And the people who don't like antisocial
behavior peel off making so the core
cult follow maybe you don't even think
of them as the core. The cult element
becomes a larger percentage of DGG.
>> That's wildly insightful. Yes. Keep
going.
>> Re recursively emboldening Destiny to do
more and more degenerate things because
he has less and less to lose. And
finally he has crossed a line for you
where you
through some combination of it just
being too much and you maybe not being
able to
excuse
because you care about him and be you
know also because you're invested some
sunk cost.
>> Okay. Can I
>> you you left?
>> No he's cooking. Let him cook.
>> He's not. And now as a result of leaving
the non-cult part of DGG, the cult that
is left behind is attacking you.
>> You you summarized it beautifully.
>> Okay.
>> Right.
Now, I think you're talking about how I
think I think Max tries to make this
about how Destiny is like the overlord
of this. I think Destiny is a victim
inside of it. Uh, an occult can form on
accident.
>> How it forms on accident is unchecked
charisma, which is things that we're
literally talking about. Like I'm I'm
looking like a leader might genuinely
believe in their own message and possess
a magnetic personality. Okay. Mission
creep group centered around a shared
hobby, wellness, or business can become
obsessive. Creeping authoritarianism to
solve administrative or interpersonal
problems. A group may centralize
decision-m us versus them mentality. An
effort to build a tight-knit community.
members may start viewing the outside
world as toxic, hostile or inferior. The
isolation creates an environment where
the group's reality criticized her
earlier. That's why she's forgetting
that like to be a content creator, to be
destiny is probably hell.
>> He doesn't look well. Like he doesn't
look like he's having fun anymore. He
doesn't look like he's doing this on
purpose. He's obviously completely
floundering. He's completely out of
control. I mean, it's not He's getting
He's getting hate every single day. He's
obviously has to deal with things.
Um, hold on. But I but I want to uh show
how what Mr. Girl just said, which I
felt was insightful, particularly the
part where you recognize that as the
quote unquote chill part of DGG has less
of an influence within the community,
the toxic element is emboldened. And
then also the toxic element, uh, since
the cool people are already gone, the
amount of people who are willing to
criticize, the amount of people who are
willing to do, I thought that was
perfectly well articulated. Now to show
how what Leah said is not contradictory
though. Um I feel like Vosch, I feel
like Lauren Southern, I feel like
Destiny and I feel like Nick Fentes um
have been trapped in what I call gilded
cages. So effectively they have
attracted an audience that has a set of
beliefs and they've gone they've
hundreds of thousands of views, maybe
millions of views, hundreds of thousands
of dollars, sometimes millions of
dollars. They are materially well off.
They have succeeded in the world of
content creation. But what has happened
is because they have rammed such a
hardcore principled ideological
uh frame like over and over and over
again. if they try to leave that frame
in any way whatsoever, they effectively
get like [__] on by the community that
they've created to get back in the box
and keep producing the content that
their audience wants to hear. And so for
me, um, I look at Vosch, I I look at,
uh, Stephen, I look at, uh, Nick Fentes,
and I'll admit I'm jealous of the
materialism, but what I'm not jealous of
is the communities that they've
cultivated, because I feel like the
communities that they cultivated will
never let them be free of their own um,
cult of personality
and what it's built around.
>> What do you think, Max?
>> I'm just letting them think.
>> Yeah, I think I think you're right. I
don't think it's contradictory. I think
as a nonsequittor to talk about how
Destiny feels again. It's just
>> then where where would you like to go
next, Max?
>> This is where I want to go. I want to
make the comment that
it feels like we can't talk about it's a
cult without also talking about oh but
what Destiny's overwhelmed or something
like it just I just don't I don't think
it's labusion.
I think there's a lot
>> Leah and I still have sympathy or him.
>> I have sympathy for him. It just doesn't
cloud my I I don't think it clouds my
thinking about whether it's a cult.
>> I don't think it clouds my Well, I'm in
the middle. I I still think it's a cult
just accidentally.
>> Why would it matter?
>> We're all different. We would matter how
it views on this, I guess.
>> What is the purpose of Jews, five
opinions?
>> Yeah. I mean from from like a mental
health perspective like obviously I hope
that Steven gets help genuinely. I mean
from from a someone who's a victim of
him.
>> I don't know why we are talking about
why are we talking I don't know why we
keep talking
>> yeah you're you're muddying the waters
by basically trying to make it Steven
focused. I muddied the waters by making
it Steven focused by sweeping for him by
blaming the women. How is it not the
waters?
What do you how does it not
>> Max and how it's it shouldn't be Stephen
Focus if we're talking about
>> because it feels sweepy.
>> It feels sweepy. At some point I'm going
to just call Max be like, "Hey, you want
to come?"
>> It's just like not a response to the
It's like just not a response to the
last thing that was said. It's just
vomiting out random stuff so that we're
not talking about anything and it just
feels like that's that's DGG. It's like
there's a thing you're not allowed to
talk about.
>> Okay. There's a thing you're not allowed
to talk about. And the thing is
immoralizing
and and really
quantifying and accounting for the harm
done by Destiny and DGG. And instead of
talking about that, we have to compare
it to other communities and other
creators. We have to talk about his
mental health and how it's affecting
him. We have to talk about how
intentional is it? And it's like I I can
I quantify the specific harm
No, I want to clarify this I wanted
>> I want to talk about this situation.
>> Yeah, if you want to.
>> Okay.
>> So, I can't help but think that when
Britt and Devil first contacted me that
when they told me that they were
military veterans dealing with mental
health issues, I became more protective
of them. I conscious, subconscious,
whatever.
I'm sure that on a like it was in there
somewhere, right?
>> And so when I think of people who have
been through the service, I know how
tough that can be. When I think about
people who have military related trauma,
it's MST. Um they I I know what that's
like. I know what that's been like. I
have friends who are like that. Um, so I
think I probably
while being repulsed by the allegations,
I was also more sympathetic to them as
victims of of Steven's misbehavior. And
so, um, when I gave him, in my opinion,
a shot across the bow in November where
I say, you know, I basically ran with
the narrative that you're talking about
where I'm being sympathetic to his
perspective and I'm worried about his
public reputation and blahy blahy blah
blah.
I think that any sane person who wasn't
self-destructive would have heard that
shot across the bow and been like,
"Damn, my friend for the past year who's
kind of been like, you know, maintained
orbit, maintained his friendship, gone
shooting with me. He's kind of calling
me out on my bad behavior and I'm
putting people at risk that he, you
know, potentially cares about. Maybe I
should back the off and do the
responsible thing." And so to find out
that he's still talking to Brit within
the past,
>> he's obviously not any of those things.
He's not the same person.
What happens to that is
>> doesn't give a [__] what happens to
Devil. Doesn't give a [__] what happens
to Brit.
>> And um what he's doing now in my opinion
is me exposing it. Brit is uh she
waffles um between
and endless devotion and love for
Steven. She literally flip-flops between
the two depending on the day and the
hour. It re So
love for Stephen, right? And so to me,
by exposing it, I'm increasing her
chances of herself. But guess what?
That's not my sin to bear. That's his.
He was mentally ill. He knew that she
was mentally ill within five minutes. He
got a shot across the stop it.
>> He uh was sat on it for 6 months. He
continued to communicate with her. So
100%
he is playing with the lives of other
people and if they end up themselves or
god forbid
out about the entire situation because
this was an ongoing situation for months
>> and what if he killed Brit?
>> That was another entirely possible
variable to happen here. So to see that
my former friend didn't give a about
whether or not somebody else got killed
or whether or not somebody committed, I
was done with it. It wasn't something
that I was going to be able to
>> lab's not imagined the same way people
think.
>> Not the same way Conor is.
>> I can't defend it. I can't sweep for it.
I can't say it's okay. It's not okay.
It's not okay.
>> Am I correct that you see this as a
significant escalation from his past
behavior? Weirdly enough, I don't
because I think that Sherry and Anavoir
were similarly
uh manic people who could have uh messed
around with
>> Conor's opinions are mental health on
mental health are so [__] crazy.
>> I could name three more.
>> Yeah, I mean, if you want to name them,
you can just ram the point home. I'm
thinking of Sherry and Anavoir. Who are
you thinking of?
>> I'm thinking about like Baby Peach. I'm
thinking about uh the Pixie who said she
was going to kill herself. Like I'm
thinking like there's obviously I mean
there's obviously like a there's a
there's a
>> No, Pixie. No, I I should I think the
reason I might have even preempted
Sorry, real quick. Mind
>> leaving. I might have even preempted
mentioning Pixie because I know that the
narrative is, oh well, she's just
baiting. Like I already know they're
already going to dismiss it. But hold
on. with Sherry and Anavoir. I think
they're undismissable cases,
>> guy.
>> Vulnerable people
>> who could be pushed past the brink and
yet what happens to them doesn't matter.
>> I'm asking
how you square not leaving before if you
don't think this is an escalation.
>> Maybe I thought I could fix him.
>> We all think we could fix our boyfriends
and husbands.
>> WHY DID HE SAY THAT? I
>> does he not know how hard he's going to
get meme for saying that?
>> I think that Steven has been so
routinely betrayed
>> by people who suck up to him,
>> hang out with him, say he's the best
thing since sliced bread,
>> take his money, take his,
take his that.
>> And then when it's convenient, they
a knife jab a knife in his back and then
they dip out. So, I only found out like
I knew about I knew about Brit saying
that they did age play, but it was like
babysitter or something. That was her
story in November. Then the husband
obviously alleged what Britt wrote into
your calling show. No, she did alleged
>> she like she liked the stream. It was
under her own Substack and her own
Substack was linked to her Discord.
So anyways,
>> point is Oh, and then she also admitted
to it in direct messages with Stephen
that had been screenshotted and posted
to the internet
>> allegedly.
>> So
>> allegedly. So So the point is that I
only found out about Brit allegedly
writing in that email to your show on
Saturday, Sunday, something like that.
like after after the may it might have
been Saturday before I confronted
Stephen or it could have been after. I'd
have to check the the logs. But the
point is that this has been an evolving
process for the past week. But what
triggered this was Friday.
And the triggering point on Friday was
not that Steven was a self-destructive
freak. It's that he thought that he
could leverage our relationship into the
way that I controlled my community
without evidence.
>> That was the problem.
>> And I basically like uh I know this
isn't the most exciting content on the
world.
>> Yeah, my watch time was
>> I actually wrote
reasonable ask highlighted in green,
unreasonable ask in red. Okay. And the
reasonable ask was, um, don't let
snarkers into my community to end or
into your community to endlessly talk
[__] about me. That's a reasonable ask.
I should not be permitting random Twitch
and YouTube political members to
obsessively talk about Steven. That's
reasonable.
>> I don't I don't think that reasonable.
That's cult.
>> Well, hold on. Hold on. Because I'll
tell you the implicit threat that I
inferred from the scenario, which is
since these people are critical of me
and they're not that important to your
community, your community is not going
to be mo made or broken off of these
people, you should ban them in order to
keep associating with me. That was the
implicit threat. And so, not only did I
write the implicit threat, but Mutton
called into the stream before Destiny
called into the stream later, and I
said, "Hey, I'm kind of inferring this
implicit threat based off of what's
being said right now. Am I getting this
right?" And he was like, "Yep,
that was it. We we are threatening to
And obviously there there's a huge uh
clout cross-pollination
financial benefit to collaborating with
Stephen, especially when you're a small
creator. Um, so as soon as Mutton
confirmed the implicit threat, I was
like, "Okay, you you know that that
that's kind of my attitude because like
if we have a six-year online debate
relationship and we have a one to
twoyear
IRL friendship, which really we've only
hung out like a half a dozen times, but
obviously I cared about it. He said that
he cared about it.
And you think you can strongarm me into
the way that I manage my community? you
that that means that you have no respect
for me whatsoever. You think that if you
clap a couple of times, I'll suck your
you um so that's the attitude I took on
Friday and then everything spiraled from
there. So that's what I have to say.
It's 12:35. I'm 5 minutes past uh tea
time. So, okay. Well, as noisy as this
conversation was, I did have fun. I know
that uh Max might not have wanted to
have fun in this conversation. No, he
needed to be very serious. It's a very
serious matter.
>> It was it was interesting and fun to
reconnect with y'all. And as much as we
disagree about a whole host of
I wish you the very best.
>> Okay.
>> I wish you the best, too.
>> Yes. Thank you for coming on.
>> All right.
Bye, guys.
>> Bye. You little piece of
do the same that you always do.
Your moral superiority.
Get that sparkle out of your eye.
>> Put that
>> You just put it in. You can't put a
sparkle in my eye and tell me to take it
out immediately.
>> Wipe that smile off of your mouth.
>> How do you do a little Well,
>> you
>> bother me so bad with your like you are.
You're the doctor. This I'm actually
going to call you the doctor.
>> I'm going to call you. You're the
psychiatrist.
You want to join? You want JSCLK to
join?
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Uh JCLK, I think that you probably
you have some insights.
>> Hello.
>> Have anything to hide?
>> Hi.
>> Hey, bud.
>> How's it going?
>> A little uh emotional.
>> Yeah, you guys were kind of It seemed
like seemed like Max in Max basically
insulted Lav early on. I can't even
remember what she said and Lav was just
she spent the rest of the conversation
getting even with you.
>> Getting even.
>> Getting even a little bit. Yeah. Yeah.
just a little bit setting up my stream.
>> Uh like the whole conversation
>> like what did I say that was getting
even
>> it was just he was trying to get
something done or whatever and you know
>> it's not getting even. It's not getting
even. I just have different I have
different thoughts about it. I I come
from a from a from a place of um
I don't know. No, I think I think this
is more interesting than I think uh that
I'm like a victim of something. Like I'm
more analytical about it than Max is
more emotional about it. Like I I that's
the difference. It's not It's not that
like It's not that I was trying to get
him. It's just that I have different
goals of the conversation and what I
want to talk about. And you know,
>> I was saying you were trying to get Max
after he kind of pointed out that you
were not going the direction you wanted
to go.
>> Yeah, but I didn't we weren't we didn't
have to be in cahoots.
That's true. That's true.
>> You were You were subverting my goal.
>> You were subverting mine, too.
>> I know.
>> So, what Well, I actually I actually
don't know what you guys wanted to
achieve, but I kind of wanted to talk
like where where were both of you
planning to go there, Max? Some people
in chat kind of thought you were
thinking along the lines of like, I
don't want to push you back into this
thing like when people first leave
cults.
>> That's interesting. Uh, I wasn't I I
mean I don't think he's going back. I
wasn't worried about that. Um, I just
want to
I don't know. It feels like a kind of a
public service. I just I I do think it's
a cult and I think people who are
watching who are kind of like I don't
know maybe this is weird are are best
served and I think Connor himself are
best served by like I think I think it
it preserves the cult to have every
single per like the number of exorbiters
is so large now and they all hate each
other. They're all like, "Well, yeah."
They're like,
>> "I know that like it's a cult and they
say everybody who criticizes Destiny is
like an evil person, but everybody who
left before me actually is a bad
person." And so, I think just like
showing up and being nice to Connor is a
way to kind of implicitly challenge that
narrative of like
>> I
especially given that he and I said
almost identical things and had and had
almost identical experiences of like I'm
trying to be your friend, but like
you're being a horrible person and I
have to criticize you or I'm going to be
enabling that and then when I criticize
you then now I see now I'm just one of
the bad people. So I was trying to
not like deprogram him but
basically
>> be his therapist and his uh his doctor.
That's what you're trying to do.
>> Sponsor is be his sponsor.
>> Yeah. He was your patient. He was your
patient. like everyone's your patient.
Everyone becomes your patient even
though you are up and don't know what's
going on either.
>> So considering considering you had that
goal and you put forethought into that,
do you think it was particularly
egregious that lab was doing the thing
you were trying explicitly not to do?
>> I really I didn't think it through. I
should have told I guess I thought that
she was going to I don't know why I
thought this.
I thought that she would want to do the
same thing.
Hearing myself say it, it's just
hilarious. But
>> yeah,
>> I thought she would at least let me do
it. Famous last words.
>> Lab, could you just lie there and not
move? Could you just lie there and not
move for
>> Exactly.
>> I get it. Yeah.
>> Yeah.
But didn't work out that way.
>> That's fair. That's fair.
>> What are you laughing about?
>> Um
>> I thought that you I thought we were
going to be on the same page. I thought
you were going to thought you going to
let me
>> When are we ever
>> I thought you going to let me do my
thing and you didn't.
>> You said that you didn't even want to be
there.
>> Yeah.
>> You're okay. So, you both You're like
You're like, "Yeah, I don't know." And
then I'm like, "It's okay. If you're
uncomfortable, you can leave. I'll take
the reins basically." And then you But
then somehow you got in there and were
like, "I'm going to take the reins."
Which like, "Okay."
>> It just didn't feel safe what you were
doing.
>> What do you mean safe?
say a vulnerable person and he's getting
dogpiled by a cult. I mean, it's he's
and
>> it's not that serious, dude. It's not
that serious. All I need to do is log
off.
>> It is
It is pretty pretty brutal. It's pretty
bad.
>> Oh my god.
>> Not anymore. Maybe while we were Maybe
while we were going through it and it
was really brutal because
>> Yeah. When it happened to us that was
serious, but now that
>> Well, no, he because he still he still
had credibility. He still had
credibility and there were still people
who were like kind of normal people that
were on his side. Now he only has
>> even just reading like YouTube comments
and and tweets is like
just having so many different usernames
all pariting the same
narrative about you.
Even if there's no like reach to it and
it doesn't matter, it's still really
reallyed up like to experience that. And
well, we all know that. I feel like you
know that. I think all three of us know
that.
>> I don't know if you guys saw Did you
guys see that he tweeted a picture of
Connor's kid?
>> Yeah, I did see that during it.
>> Like,
>> no.
>> why did he do that?
>> Uh, while you guys were talking
>> 15 minutes ago. Yeah.
>> Yeah. He's like,
>> what does the tweet say?
>> That he like accused Yeah. He accused he
was like the real reason he didn't want
me to talk about this or something is
because he was sending me uh
age play. He was doing age play with me
and it was like a picture of him holding
his like baby
>> with like the eyes crossed out.
>> Yeah. Um
>> cuz even his his even his audience was
like
>> Yeah. That thinking his audience was
going to be on board with that is
>> this is what I'm saying. Like he's
losing it. He's completely losing it.
He's not there anymore. Like he's got
all the room in the world to lose it and
fall and people will try to catch him.
It's a at any point he like wakes up and
stops acting like this. He would be
fine.
So he's going for
the person I was with doing age play
with sending me pictures allegedly
was they just because they were sending
me pictures doesn't mean it's age play
related to the pictures and so therefore
when Connor does it this proves
>> that
I see the I see the logic
Well, that does seem That does seem like
a really
weird thing to do. I How is Connor going
to react? I'm surprised that he would do
that.
Destiny deleted the tweet apparently.
And I don't know if Connor is going to
react or not. I Connor might react.
Connor is a conservative. I He could
react badly.
>> I mean, it's such a betrayal. like he's
obviously sending him the picture of
like to bond with him as a friend
>> or I mean it could be public too. I have
no idea.
I I hope it's not a if it if it was like
a DM picture
but it's
>> it's fair game to Destiny because he
called them a
>> uh it's a fairly closeup detailed
picture. It's not like it's not I'll
just describe it. He's like holding his
in right in front of the camera. It's
it's a
objectively up to tweet out in this
situation for sure.
>> I'll put the I'll put the text on. I
didn't want to say anything, guys, but
the reason Conor's freaking out so much
right now is because he was the one
trying to do age play by sending me
pictures of his
well.
>> Yeah,
>> it's also just not funny.
>> It's also just like not funny.
>> That's like almost all of his tweets
lately. But
>> Right. Well, that's what I'm saying.
He's completely losing it. His only
audience remaining are people who are
like completely
either hate him and think he's a l cow
and are like, "This is my goat. Like,
this is my goat, lol." Or like, you
know, people who are like hyper and like
like have caregivers.
>> Yeah. I I think what what I don't see
that he he just can't understand this
that like there are people with
legitimacy who want to interact with him
because he's got a big audience, right?
>> Yeah.
>> But like he's consistently drawing their
attention to things that aren't anything
to do with his political opinion that
look terrible. Like absolutely terrible
for him. And I don't know I don't know
why he doesn't see that. Like there's
something going on there. There's a
blindness going on with him right now
where he can't see outside of his cult.
>> Survival mode.
>> He's making the worst decisions
imaginable.
>> He's in survival mode right now. He's
like he thinks that he's fighting for
his life. Like he'll go into like a 700
viewer stream and like fight for his
life. Like he literally is he's
spiraling. Like he go like he can just
ignore all of it is the craziest thing.
Like he could ignore every single thing
and he doesn't. He's obsessed with it.
He's obsessed with himself. He's
spiraling. He's desperate. He's like,
he's impulsive. He's emotional. Like
he's completely out of control. He I
think that he does have like genuine
BPD. Like Like I think um Connor Connor
was like, "Oh, he's a sociopath." No,
he's not. No, he's not at all. He's
absolutely on the other side of this
spectrop. He's not a sociopath. He's
like he's obviously like he's obviously
borderline obviously insecure. a
narcissist. It is what it is. How could
he not be? He's been online for a
million years. This is like this it
trains you to do that. How could he not
be? He's like he's like this like ugly,
you know, pear-shaped guy with breasts.
Suddenly has all this attention online.
Like this is this is all he has. This is
literally all he has. He does not have a
life outside of this. He's nobody
without destiny. Nobody. So he's like
he's fighting for his life every single
day to keep destiny. I can't imagine.
I'd actually I mean, can you even
imagine how brutal that would be?
>> What uh did you guys not get to any
questions or topics that you thought you
were going to get to?
>> I'm I mean, I really just thought it'd
be interesting to all of us get in a in
a room and see what we talked about. And
I think it was interesting. Um but I did
I did ask like about the Predator thing,
like whether or not he was a Predator.
and um he was
like actually just but he's always been
that so I wasn't actually shocked but
you know it is what it is and then I
wanted to talk about agency and what
agency meant like I really wanted to
like break it down in a way where I was
like kind of um you wanted to be like
yeah this you know this is this is
happening to you and we've all been here
and you're deprogramming but I wanted to
like kind of shake him awake. I wanted
to be like, "Okay, well, let's follow
your thought processes and break them
down one by one. See why you believe
that. Why do you believe the things that
you do?" Like, I wanted to rip his mind.
Um,
>> yeah. But the whole reason that
situation,
>> the whole reason he and any of us were
in that situation is because we couldn't
tolerate cognitive dissonance. So,
>> at the exact moment that it's starting
to resolve and he's being dogpiled for
it, I feel like just laying on more
cognitive dissonance of being like,
"What? idea, but you said this and then
you said this and you think this and now
this is happening and what about this?
How do you swear all that and just like
seeing if he'll freak out or
>> No, it's not seeing if he'll freak out.
It's seeing if he'll have an epiphany
and be like, "Wait, I don't know why I
believe the things that I believe."
That's it's it's a philosophical
discussion of like if you break this
down, can you explain to me with your
core of self what you know about
yourself and your value system how this
tracks? I think that the even the way
you're saying it now where you're trying
to not sound like you're needling just
sounds like needling. It sounds like you
are trying to just
make him explode.
>> Okay. You're sensitive.
I like do I you're I Yeah, I don't think
that that would happen with him.
>> I don't think that his emotions are so
volatile that he would explode if he was
probed.
>> I think that he would probably just put
walls up. Lock down. Yeah, is what I was
going to say. I was going to say lock
down is what I think. He doesn't
explode. He just locks down.
>> It's difficult to have a combo.
>> And I wanted I wanted
>> That's true. He was extremely open to
me.
>> I wanted
>> I've talked to Connor multiple times.
I've talked to him a billion times. He's
very susceptible and he's very He's very
open.
>> Multiple. No, say billion. That'll do
it. No, I want I wanted to create a safe
space and it felt like you
didn't.
What is safe about any like what is
safety? I this whole safety thing it's a
fallacy.
>> Safety is knowing that you are allowed
to say you that you're wrong about
something or you've changed your mind
about something and no one is going to
be like I told you so.
>> I'm never I was never going to say I
told you so.
>> It feels like you did.
>> No, I was if he came to the same
conclusions as me, I'd be like well
that's where that's where I got to after
I did my journey. I this I got to very
similar places. That's what I would have
said. It wasn't like an I told you so.
It was like, yeah, I got there, too. Or
if he didn't,
>> I felt like
>> I'd be like, well, I did not come to
that conclusion myself. We have
different values.
>> I felt like the point where you were
making it that you were making about how
he basically hasn't had agency anywhere.
That felt like um
>> Oh, yeah.
>> I told you so. Like I like I feel like
if I went back and watched the VODs and
maybe this isn't true, but I feel like
if I went back and watched VODs of like
the whole breakup thing if you ever
talked to Connor, I feel like that's
what you'd be telling him is like you
don't have any agency. You're a part of
a cult. You don't even know what's going
on.
>> Yeah. You're like your whole life
>> you've been a little lost lamb and DG
attracts people like you.
>> That's that's I told you so
>> a little bit.
>> No. So, I'm I'm functioning off of I'm
functioning off of the idea that he
>> Well, it came from him saying that he is
anti antisocial behavior, right? That's
what he said moments before I tried to
see what his value system was and tried
to hold it up.
>> You're reframing that as mindless
conformity.
>> Not necess
No, I think that you were having a
conversation that I was not having and
you thought that I was having a
conversation I wasn't having because I
was not doing that. I was trying to find
the peaks and the cracks of his value
system
and also like okay if you have your
whole life sort of followed schools of
thought like DG or
>> that
yeah
>> or or all of that then I wonder then I
wonder what is the core of that like
what is the what is the core of that
what are what is the through line
between all
>> you're calling you're calling his
religion and his military
>> and Where is your
>> belief system a mindless cult? You're
saying
>> no I'm not. You don't. No. This is why
you piss me off. This is why you piss me
off because you think that you read my
mind and you don't. That's not This is
why you do that pisses me off. I don't
do that. I was literally going to
>> I read your words. I read your tone. I
read your face. I read
>> my tone. Maybe. My tone. Maybe. My tone.
Maybe. I'll give you that. is my tone is
I'm I have a really hard time with my
tone and managing my tone.
>> You know, your mind is hooked up to all
the stuff you're doing and saying,
>> "No, I'm I'm like a very my tone is
something that's completely different
from my brain, I think. And I I do have
to work on that actually." But no, I was
literally trying to come from like his
his sense of values, identity, and then
have a more honest conversation from
there. Okay.
>> Lack of identity.
>> No, it's not. Nobody has a lack of
identity.
>> Yo, you're attacking his lack of
>> Nobody has a lack of identity. I didn't
think that he didn't have an identity.
I wanted to see what his core was, what
he thought about himself, and why he had
the authority to talk about,
what was moral, why he believed that
this was the right choice, why he like
that was a more interesting conversation
to me. And I'll probably still have it
with Connor and you'll see that I'm not
trying to do that.
>> Well, you know the you know what the
answer is, right? He believes that like
commitment and loyalty are very
important values that you should hold.
So it's not that it's mindless. It's
that he thinks that even if there are
rock if there's like bumps in the road,
you should remain committed on a path.
>> People need very few bumps in the road
to start re-evaluating changing things.
>> Well, I a very bumpy road.
>> I had a feeling that it would come to
something like that like un like maybe
at least with this friendship with
Steven unconditional love and then also
endurance and resilience. Like that's
what I thought it was going.
Uh maybe, but I didn't have the chance
to even have that conversation because
Max wanted to have the conversation
about how he's better than everyone
because he he sees the cult for what it
is.
>> Well, I think that the resistance to
my goals itself is kind of a
demonstration of what I'm talking about.
So, I was happy.
>> I want to you.
>> I get it. Yeah.
both that you want to kill him and what
Max is saying.
>> No. And you did, you know, and you did
the same and you did the same thing.
>> Oh, yeah. Here we go. Here it comes.
>> Lav, you look very skinny right now,
just so you know.
>> Thanks. You did the same thing. you like
tried to mindread me, but it was in a
like misogynistic and way where you
thought that I I could not have had
anything to add that was like that was
salient or like or
>> um or or good or like
>> you like assumed that the place I was
going was like a negative place.
um which was
>> that you do often and it sets the tone
because you are especially with Connor
because one you're a man and he's a
misogynist and two it sets the tone for
the audience because you're a man and
I'm a woman.
>> Yes.
>> And I'm me and you're you. And it it
also like you know you you you don't
give me the opportunity to show that
like no I actually know what's going on.
I am asking questions that are pointed
for a reason and they're not going to a
bad place because I'm just a person
built off of spite and evil and and you
don't even let me get to the meat of it.
You don't even let me like be normal
now. I'm like typ casted and you keep me
there
>> as a horrible woman.
>> Yes. It bothers me bad. You've done this
separate. You do this every time we're
live. I think I also what's worse is
that I acknowledge it afterward every
time.
>> Yeah, you do.
>> You say this every time and then I'm
like, "Yeah, you're right."
>> Mhm.
>> And then I do it again.
>> You're like, I know you were doing
something bad and I'm just like, dude,
I'm literally You didn't even let me get
You didn't You didn't let me get
literally at one point I said four words
and you shut me out before I could get
there. Like you did not let me
>> No, you literally did not let me finish
a sentence before you were like you're
drilling into him and I'm like dude I'm
I'm probing him and trying to have a
conversation where like we understand
each other.
I think I am trying
to get across my concerns about the cult
structure by not even downplaying but
accurately portraying the extreme lack
of agency that I see in its memory.
>> Yeah. And I think
>> because we did I know that's what we're
disagreeing about. So then, so where I
see somebody who's basically helplessly
a kite in a hurricane,
>> but none of us were.
Not even one of us were.
>> That is not the conclusion that I
reached.
>> Okay. Well, I think that that's
>> that's not where I'm at. That's not
where I ended up.
>> Okay. Well, all all of us all of us have
agency and I did not end up at the same
place as you. And I think that maybe
taking a little bit more responsibility
for my part is what's I think propelled
me into a different sort of person. In
some ways, I've tried to take a lot out
of this situation and been like, you
know what, I had a lesson to learn. I
had my own part in it. I have to take
responsibility for my actions inside of
it. This is who I'm going to be moving
forward. And I think that that was more
helpful to me than just being like, I'm
a victim of this person.
Well, maybe more helpful to you or feel
better, but that doesn't make it true.
>> Okay.
>> You want to know what's funny? The first
thing I thought as Lav was explaining
that was I was like, I really um I had
to figure out how to stop Max from
trying to say that like whatever piece
you have could be elucery. I that was
exactly where my head went. And then
>> you weren't fast enough.
>> I was very slow. Yeah, I was very slow.
>> Um
>> Okay. I mean, this isn't something that
affects me anymore at all, like at all.
So, I think I took the I think I took
the right way out. I I also haven't had
any sort of degragation of any sort of
relationship since then. Like, I I've
I've been on the up. I've learned how
I've I've learned a lot about myself
intrapersonally and interpersonally.
So, I mean, even taking
>> I was just going to say even if you
hadn't, I don't think that would
necessarily mean you were still affected
by it or still like in all of it in some
way. Even if you'd been having a rough
time, I think you could easily have
moved past this, right? It's it's good
that you're thriving. It's good that
school's going good. You're writing a
book. Your marriage is going well.
That's all great. I'm just saying that
even if you weren't, like it wouldn't
necessarily mean that you had [__] up
somehow.
>> Destiny broke me. My career died. my
girlfriend left me and I went bald.
>> Other than that, things are going well.
>> Other than that,
>> that's not what I'm saying either. I'm
I'm It's It's not even the fact that my
life is better and like that my, you
know, I'm going to school and I have a
husband who I love. It's like it's just
like I I g I gained necessary
experience, but I also was only 22 when
it happened. So like I was 23 when
everything was happening. So it's like I
was a freshly jellied baby into the
world. And I I in a lot of ways I got to
move on um in a big way which you know
and I talked to you about this I think
like months ago where I was like in some
ways like you did not get that you had
this like burgeoning career that you had
cultivated that you had cultivated and
then you sort of had it like ripped from
you and burned to the ground. So, we're
coming from maybe I was just harmed less
than you were.
And I and honestly, I also got some
really good licks in. Like, if you would
have gotten a couple of licks in, maybe
you would have felt different, but I got
a lot of really good licks in. So,
I don't know. All you know, it's to me
it was just war and I won.
That's how I feel.
>> Okay. I don't know. So,
the amount of sensitivity I was showing
to Connor
threatens your narrative that you won.
>> What
>> is that what you're trying to say?
>> Your what? Me me me me me me me me me me
me me me me me me me me me me me me me
me me me me me me me being being really
sensitive to Connor threat by
implication threatens your narrative
that that you won or that it was war and
I'm acting him I'm acting like he's
>> No, I think I think it
>> I think it threatens my agency period.
>> Yes.
>> And also what I think is one of my
values which is um introspection
over being right or being a victim.
Like it was more valuable to me to
introspect about that situation than to
um than to tell everyone that I was a
victim of someone.
>> But that's like guided introspection
that has to lead to a conclusion that
you're not a victim.
>> No, I still think that I'm I still think
that I was a victim. Like in
>> this is what I'm saying. This is where
it's fuzzy. It's like are the are we are
are we victims? Are we mentally ill? Do
we have agency?
Did we win? Was it just a fight? Did we
get good listen? Do we
>> both? First of all, both and all things
can be true depending on how you look at
them. And that's true about everything
in the world.
>> That Yeah, but that depending on how you
look at it, I think is part of the
cult. That's part of the
>> Max. No, that's about life. You're But
this is your own is that you're just
uncomfortable with life and its
realities.
This is this is a deeper thing.
>> I'm bald. Don't tell me about reality.
>> He's bald and he's torturing people out
of hair.
I see the same thing. I don't know if
you've ever watched any of um like Pisco
talk, but Pisco has gotten into some
tussles with DG recently and people act
like they can't understand him. And to
me, it's like I'll literally walk with
him while he's talking and I'll pause
and I'll explain the exact direction
he's going, what argument he's about to
make. And it's like it's so easy to
understand. And then I feel the same way
for Max. I know where he's going, what
he's trying to say, what he's trying to
get to, and why the thing he's saying is
actually important. But I don't think
Live's doing that from a cult
perspective. I think Live's doing that
from a She's from interrupting her
perspective.
>> I feel the same way. I Me and Max have
no problem talking oneon-one. We
understand each other. I know what he's
going to say. He knows what I'm going to
say. When you're talking to someone like
Connor who needs to be like like a dog,
like told exactly the point so he
doesn't meander like he was, like he
literally continued to. That's the
problem. M
>> at least to the point
>> maybe Connor Connor has a problem of he
needs to use anecdotes. He's like
thought of one way to to make his point.
>> Yeah.
>> So he's always going to use that point
and he's going to use like an anecdote
that goes with that point and that could
like sometimes make a point in 20 words,
but he will take like 10 minutes.
>> It feels like a it does feel like a
defensive measure when he does it.
>> Uh I've seen it used that way. Yes, I've
seen it used that way.
>> I agree that Pisco is a very organized
speaker. Yeah, I just wasn't sure if you
I I've been following like quite a bit
of that podcast because Pisco and Hutch
have like a podcast with a couple other
people and I I listen to it a decent
amount and
>> it's interesting how that podcast has
sort of been subsumed into some DG
adjacent drama as well. Feels like the
the tentacles are far reaching
sometimes.
>> Yeah. So you
>> crazy made me
>> that's
in your head.
>> It's not. It's good one though. You're
just imagining it.
>> Good one. Right. That's a really good
one.
>> I hope that you realize what you just
did in the self and I hope you have
self-awareness,
>> but it I fear that you actually did that
on accident.
>> Wait, no. Max was definitely making a
joke. Come on.
>> No, I fear I fear that it actually
wasn't.
>> Did you see him look in the camera when
he said it?
>> After after all these years, you don't
trust me just a little bit.
>> No.
if I would trust you more if you if you
held me in high regard publicly.
>> I Oh, that's that's tough. You know that
sometimes. Okay. I watched this
conversation. There were times where I
think if Max wasn't on camera, I feel
like he would have gotten up and like
punched a wall. I think him not like
getting mad at you at all was sort of
because he holds you in high regard. He
doesn't want to
>> He did get mad at me, but he was No, he
did get mad at me, but it was like
passive aggression
>> and it was on his face. and he was
saying things that were undermining in a
way that was like whatever. It's I mean
I'm not going to do this publicly
because I already know what I'm setting
myself up for when I'm advocating for
myself in public. So
>> I agree with you. I agree with you.
>> We're both going back and forth and
doing it. I I had the impression that
you did it first, but it doesn't make it
okay when Max does it back.
>> I think I undermined you. I think I was
and I think I I think I overreacted
to my sensitivity
to Connor and I think I threw you under
the bus and made you look like a crazy
attempted to make you look like a crazy
one. If we go back the points that I
made that were uninterrupted by you,
maybe I got maybe I got one and a half
out before you said that before you
stopped me by saying it was evil and
that it was bad and that it was off the
and if it was off the mark.
>> I think that it was evil.
>> No, I don't think it was evil. I think
it was just kicking a guy while he's
down. And and I understand he's also
kicking you while while he's down. You
made that.
>> I don't think I did. I think he's while
he's down and you're like kind of
kicking him back.
>> Conor and I are friendly. I was not
trying to do that. I was not trying to
do that at all and I wasn't going to.
And I think you'll see that in our
conversation
in my one-on-one conversation with him.
I think that you'll see exactly what I
was trying to do and it wasn't
>> the I think he was in a vulnerable
position and he was being and I think
that that puts you in a bad spot where
you have to enable it by not reacting or
you have to fight back and then you look
and I think I contributed to that by
trying to protect
>> the way that I fight back is
>> just being normal and not and not
falling into the trap.
>> You were I think you were needling him.
>> No, I wasn't. No, I wasn't. But I do
think I overreacted and did do the thing
that you're accusing me of doing. It's
in both of our heads. And since it's in
my head, that makes it real. So
>> yeah, cuz you're
>> making it up.
>> I hate you. You drag me through the town
square calling me a victim. And then
when I and then when I then I when I try
to rise above and
you're keeping me at you're keeping me
at 22year-old Lavloon online. That's
where you're keeping me. Is that more
comfortable for you?
For me, for me to be the victim and for
you to be the brain,
for me for me to just be your unruly
friend who just says the crazy thing and
actually not have any insight. Does that
make you feel good? For you to be the
insightful one, Max? Does that make you
feel good?
I bet it does.
>> I don't know about you guys, but
sometimes I sometimes I'm just sitting
there and I open my mouth and
a lie just sort of like rolls out. I
actually don't know the precise quote.
>> And here we go. Huh? And here we go.
>> I'm laughing. I'm laughing because I
don't see you that way. Okay. You know
that I don't see you that way, right?
>> You do to some extent. That's why you
brought it up.
>> I think it's a stuck here. And I'm stuck
here.
>> All clip.
>> No matter how good I behave. Huh?
>> Time clip.
>> No matter how good I behave, I'm stuck
here.
>> I mean, let's not let's not be
unreasonable and act like you behave
well. most of the time on the internet.
But
>> how about when was the last time I badly
behaved?
>> Definitely outing Ice Boseidon as a but
also or at least in that world, but I'm
sure there's been a time since then.
>> I don't think that that's even really
badly behaved. But
>> but honestly, it's like I don't see you
that way. So, not as the, you know,
live, laugh, lie person,
>> I'm stuck here.
>> The jokes the jokes are funny.
>> That's what it is.
>> You can you can own the jokes. I think I
think you're especially because you got
all those licks in. You can definitely
own the jokes,
>> you know, and now I'm now we're in the
place where the conversation becomes
about me and I can't say anything about
myself anymore. So,
>> do you want do you want me where where
should I move it to? Do you want to go
back to I would go back to where Matt
want to talk through like the things you
would like.
>> I'd like to resp I'd like to respond to
Leo.
>> Okay, go.
>> If that's okay. Okay. I think
that part of my trauma from my DGG
experience is feeling hyper responsible
in a way I already did but it was made
worse
uh specifically for you and around you
and other ex other defectors. And I do
think that that
excessively
protectionist, controlling, patriarchal,
paternal instinct
is all the things that you're saying it
is. Yes. Yes. I am
>> You You made me You stuck me You stuck
me in my position.
>> I'm here forever.
>> Yes.
>> And I can't And I can't get out of it.
And and this and the second I say I've
overgrown it or I've
>> You can't grow. You can't leave. No.
Yes. You I can't move on or heal.
>> You are the devouring mother.
>> But you'll be safe.
>> You are the devouring mother. But that's
not even what's making me safe because
part of what these people want to kill
me for and what they're like, you know,
their criticisms of me are all the
things where you keep me. All the all
the places you keep me. I can't be
insightful. I can't be intelligent. all
I I mean I ask a couple probing
questions and I can't I can't even get
there. You you've made up your mind that
it's gonna be some it's gonna go
somewhere that you know is nefarious.
>> Hold on. That actually is like a good
point that I don't know. I don't think
you were here. I think you walked away.
But I asked Max like he basically said
that he thought about this beforehand
and he wanted to treat thor gently. And
I think if you guys had coordinated a
little bit more beforehand, you wouldn't
have run into that exact
>> No, he does this every time. He does
this every time no matter what.
>> Okay.
Would have been a different thing then.
>> I'm in these I'm in these chains. He has
me shackled. He won't let me leave my
bedroom. He's not letting me have a
phone.
>> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait. So, hold on. Now, we
have to unpack that. Cuz you you felt
like I was trying to cast you a certain
way when I made the joke. Were you
trying to cast Max a certain way when
you made that joke?
>> No, I Well, I don't believe that about
him at I thought it was just a really
funny thing to say. I like I have no I
don't believe that even a little bit.
>> That's what I said. That's what I said.
>> No, but it it's different coming from
you because you weaponized that against
me for like over a year and you did
believe it and probably still do to some
extent. Whereas like I don't I've never
believed that about Max ever. That's why
it's like completely a joke when I say
it.
>> Okay.
>> But do you believe it metaphorically?
>> I don't like that you
>> I hope she believes it metaphorically
cuz she did. I don't think that you
treat I don't think that you treated
Shaylen the way that you've treated me.
>> Lab is the real Shayen. That's
>> No, no, no, no, no. It's a completely
different relationship. Completely
different. It's like it really is like
it really is the devouring mother.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Yes. I really do have like the Jordan
Peterson devouring mother. And yet, you
know, this conversation could have gone
really well for me. People would have
been like, People could have been like,
"Wow,
>> Leah's like not the same person."
>> I She's actually She's actually like,
she's actually grown up a lot.
>> Well, hold on.
>> You couldn't let me have that. Huh?
>> That hold on. That could be true. Do you
think you're ever going to get that in
these communities having any
conversation in these communities? Like
even adjacent to them.
>> Well, even in I would like for myself to
feel it in the conversation.
>> Okay, that's
>> And he wouldn't even let me have that.
Okay,
>> you did hurt my feelings though. You
will be hearing from me.
>> Okay, see you.
>> Cool.
streaming doesn't really bring out the
best in me.
>> Probably not anybody.
>> Yeah.
Yeah. No, it doesn't.
>> Might bring out the worst in me.
>> I have yet to meet the person that it
doesn't bring the worst out in
this is uh the way it is.
>> Yeah.
>> I don't know. It's I think um there's
something to be said for covering stuff
where the people don't really know about
you all that much and you just kind of
around and have fun.
I do think that once you're It feels
specifically like the um the close
relationships make the content better
between like a lot of the creators, but
it also makes it like a lot more real.
Like I think people go through genuine
mental like anguish over stuff like this
and it's um
>> yeah,
>> it gets quite difficult to process.
Also, just the more you stream with
people, the closer you get to them.
>> Yep. And then if you Well, for me, I
have an audience that likes like
dramatic content, too. So, obviously,
they're going to hope that they can egg
on any fight that could be possible.
>> Yeah.
>> Which adds like the element that is a
little difficult to deal with.
>> She's right though. These are my worst
qualities, tendencies
>> that you feel like you need to control
the conversation and be a good person
and be the smartest person who's doing
everything correct.
>> Yeah. and make specifically by making
women look bad so I can protect the egos
of men.
>> She's not the only person to that
pointed this out to me. Shayen Shaylen
said this to me quite a few times.
It gets difficult because there are
times where that argument that that
could be true and it could be happening
like at the exact same time as them
using that argument to win because they
know they're in the wrong. Like do you
know what I mean? Like that
>> I I I don't think function with
>> I Yeah. Yeah.
I don't think that what I said was not
true, but I do think
the way I did it was maneuvering in the
exact way that she is saying it was. So,
I'm not saying like, oh, I don't think
she was needling Connor or I think she
was being super nice to him. I don't I
don't but I also think that I don't know
kind of I kind of
>> like the way you pointed out the way
you're like confident about it and
undermining basically puts her in a
certain role in the conversation that
prevents her from having success in the
conversation.
>> Yes. And it makes it so that anything
she would do to get out of that role is
just interpreted as her being like
>> further cementing her in that role.
Yeah. Yeah.
>> It's a Yeah. It's like a trap.
>> Yeah. I've had that criticism as well.
So just the I I think that pretty much
that exact criticism. So
>> yes, I think I've seen that happen
before.
>> Yep. Yeah. And it's like it like I said,
I'm I'm not quite as intentful as you
are in conversations, so I'm sure I do
it in a malicious way or in a self-s
serving way far more often or at least
at least as often. Yeah. Do you have uh
you have any other topics you wanted to
talk about or
>> No.
>> No. it.
>> Yeah,
>> that's fair.
>> Yeah.
>> Do you?
>> No. Okay. Um I'm probably going to
disconnect then and just say goodbye to
everybody and then I don't know. Don't
be a stranger. I think I think you might
be in the Discord. I'm pretty sure
you're in the Discord.
>> I am.
>> You ever ever want to hop on? I know you
don't necessarily like streaming, but
>> you know, you ever want to hop on?
>> Welcome to.
>> Thank you.
I'm sure we'll talk sooner or later.
>> Yeah, for sure. All right, have a good
night.
>> You, too.
>> We'll see you around. See you. Bye.